now we thank you for joining us at 11
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise valdez a
16 year old high school student
allegedly strangled and beat his teacher
several times before sexually assaulting
her that's according to police jonathan
martinez garcia being charged as an
adult he's a junior at el dorado high
school according to a report obtained by
the 8 news now i-team police believe
martinez garteas strangled the teacher
with a computer cord now before his next
court hearing martinez garcia will be
evaluated by at least two doctors to
decide if he is competent
this case has spurred action from ccsd
to address school violence those steps
come ahead of a protest planned by
several teachers who say they don't feel
safe victoria saha has a story
teachers say it's time to take measures
into their own hands making sure the
clark county school district
administrators hear their concerns
hoping another one of their educators
are not attacked again school violence
within ccsd has been an ongoing issue
but thursday's brutal attack on an el
dorado high school teacher was the last
draw for school administrators they will
face expulsion proceedings
and will be removed from our
comprehensive schools superintendent dr
jesus jarrah now implementing new
consequences for students who assault
each other or staff members in a press
conference tuesday dr jara said all
staff will have panic buttons that will
allow them to get in contact with first
responders but i asked him why he waited
so long why did it take for a teacher to
be brutally attacked to
take such you know slip action such as a
panic button and increase in police
presence for the rest of the year i'm
going to do what i need to do to protect
our educators and
our students and i'm taking the actions
now but there was no action taken when a
secretary was attacked by a student at
legacy high school back in february this
is why several teachers are organizing a
protest wednesday morning to voice
safety concerns when we go back to
school next tuesday
i'm not going to be any more safe
because they're piloting something a
month from now alexis salt is a teacher
within ccsd she's organizing the protest
in hopes that administrators will put
teachers first before themselves the
people at the top are very well
protected but they don't deal with
children as for the panic buttons dr
jarrah says they're still figuring out
the logistics but staff at el dorado
high school will be the first to get on
the list to get one in the newsroom
victoria saha live local now the